monsieur le président madame la ministre
on a eu peur que vous ayez peur du débat
mais tard mieux que seriez avec l'eau
mes chers collègues le groupe crc a
demandé ce débat sur l'avenir d'edf et
le projet recul pour trois raisons
d'abord du fait de l'opacité des
négociations avec la commission
européenne
alors que ni les parlementaires que nous
sommes ni les usagers ni les salariés ne
sont aujourd'hui informé le pire c'est
que vous envisagez de passer par un
cavalier législatif dans le texte de la
convention citoyenne en nous demandant
de vous autoriser à légiférer par
ordonnance pour nous c'est non et je
pense que l'ensemble des groupes qui
composent cet hémicycle seront d'accord
avec nous la deuxième raison c'est qu'à
chaque démantèlement d'une entreprise
publique que ce soit france télécom gdf
ou encore la sncf les prix explosent
pour les usagers qui deviennent des
clients et les conditions de travail des
salariés se dégrade
mais le pire c'est lorsque vous livrer
un monopole naturel ou privés cela
conduit souvent à des scandales
financiers économiques et sociaux comme
les privatisation des autoroutes ou de
l'aéroport de toulouse blagnac
alors plutôt que d'attendre dix ans pour
faire une commission denquête qui
démontrera ce que nous savons déjà
chaque groupe doit se prononcer
aujourd'hui voulons nous livrer un
monopole de fait et démantelé une
nouvelle fois une entreprise publique
alors que tous nous invite à faire
exactement l'inversé
enfin vous vous abritez derrière un
argument ce projet à recul ne serait
qu'un débat très technique sur une
simple réorganisation de l'entreprise
sans conséquences pour les usagers ni
les salariés nous pensons au contraire
que ce départ est extrêmement politique
et qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité
nous voulons profiter d'ailleurs de ce
débat pour donner à toutes et tous les
clés pour bien comprendre l'énergie et
donc edf est un bien commun
indispensable à toutes et tous comme le
rappelle notre constitution et son
préambule de 1946 elle est nécessaire
pour se chauffer se laver manger mais
aussi se déplacer produire et consommer
et avec l'arrivée de la scène g
et les objets connectés les data center
les voitures électriques les besoins en
électricité et en énergie seront à
l'avenir toujours important nous avons
donc besoin d'une véritable réflexion
sur son système de production de
transport et de distribution mais
également sur la maîtrise de la demande
énergétique
loin des slogans moralisateur d'edf avec
sa campagne hashtag mais ton pull les
enjeux de souveraineté industrielle
sanitaire énergétique devrait être au
coeur des politiques publiques qui
façonneront notre économie pour les
années à venir
a contrario le choix a été fait de la
livrer aux marchés or c'est précisément
l'erreur que font les libéraux avec des
conséquences dramatiques théorisé que
l'énergie est une marchandise comme une
autre
révèle soit d'une méconnaissance totale
du sujet soit de la mise en oeuvre d'une
véritable escroquerie en bande organisée
l'énergie est le seul bien où la
production doit être absolument égal à
la consommation pour notre marché
national
même si évidemment nous pouvons être
exportateur ou importateurs quand
aujourd'hui les réseaux sont connectés
si vous produisez plus c'est la
surtension et le black out
si vous produisez - c'est là sous
tension est donc le black out
en conséquence le mythe de la
compétition en tracteur alternatif et
entreprise historique dans le but de
faire baisser les prix ne peut être
qu'un leurre car une entente entre
l'ensemble des acteurs est absolument
nécessaire pour livrer les besoins
exacts aux usagers et donc les libéraux
ont créé de toutes pièces un marché de
l'énergie qui vise non pas répondre à la
demande doit baisser les prix mais bien
à faire varier les prix artificiellement
pour garantir des dividendes aux acteurs
alternatifs et c'est précisément pour
cela que depuis un siècle
des réflexions ont été engagés pour
sortir l'énergie des lois du marché il
aura fallu il aura fallu deux tentatives
avortées la première celle de jean
jaurès en 1894 est la deuxième du front
populaire à la fin des années 30 pour
que la france nationalise
enfin le secteur de l'énergie
électricité et gaz mais aussi les mines
entre 1944 et 1947 et un statut
protecteur est également créée pour les
agents par le ministre communiste marcel
paul edf était la garantie d'égalité de
nos territoires où que vous habitiez
vous aviez accès à l'électricité à un
prix accessible au plus grand nombre
grâce aux tarifs réglementés
pourtant à partir du début des années 90
la libéralisation est lancée avec la
création de rte pour le transport et les
10 pour la distribution et recule c'est
une nouvelle étape du démantèlement et
de la déréglementation du secteur de
l'énergie puisque vous vous apprêtez à
désintégrer l'entreprise publique et à
la livre et aux marchés financiers
c'est donc une nouvelle spoliation d'un
bien commun avec pour seul résultat des
libéralisations 12 millions de personnes
en situation de précarité énergétique
des augmentations successives des tarifs
réglementés de près de 70% et les
attaques incessantes contre ses tarifs
réglementés
ce projet recul c'est l'enfant de
jupiter négocié avec la commission
européenne
d'ailleurs cette négociation est un
marché de dupes car augmenter le prix de
l'arenh pour mieux rémunérer edf
fragilisé par les investissements à
venir en contrepartie de démanteler
l'entreprise publique et de concéder des
concessions au privé sur les barrages
hydroélectriques est une hérésie
arrêtons nous un instant sur ce système
aberrant que la reine et prenons un
exemple pour mieux en comprendre la
situation
imaginons que l'on demande à renault de
vendre un quart de sa production de clio
à peugeot à prix coûtant afin que
peugeot puisse venir concurrencer
renault sur le marché automobile
vous pensez que c'est complètement fou
et bien remplacer renault par edf et
peugeot par les acteurs alternatifs
elles vous avez le système de la reine
ajoutons y la demande des alternatifs de
sortir de l'arène pendant la crise pour
aller se servir
marché de gros de l'électricité dont le
prix du mégawatt était tombé à 21 euros
contre 42 avec la reine pour les
alternatifs c'est donc fromage et
dessert et il aurait d'ailleurs tort de
s'en priver car c'est edf et les usagers
qui paye la note
n'oublions pas trop rapidement que la
reine avait été inventée soi disant pour
permettre aux acteurs alternatifs
d'investir pour produire à leur tour
résultat le néant alors que se joue que
savons-nous d'hercule et de la future
architecture d'edf
il y aura trois entités d'abord edf
bleus qui inclut le nucléaire et le
thermique à flamme et qui sera
nationalisée à 100% ensuite des verts
qui comprendrait nedis les énergies
renouvelables telles que edf outre-mer
et corse
une partie de l'activité internationale
et la direction commerciale
cette entité sera livré au privé à
hauteur de 35 % et enfin edf azur avec
les barrages hydroélectriques qui reste
république mais dont les concessions
pourraient être confiés au privé
nous envoyons trois risques en premier
lieu il faut préciser un peu on a pu
penser entendre que ce projet
reviendrait à nationaliser les dettes et
privatiser les profits
ce n'est pas tout à fait exact la force
d'une entreprise intégrée c'est que les
profits dégagés dans une branche peuvent
être réinvestis dans une autre et vice
versa par exemple on pourrait
aujourd'hui investir dans la
sécurisation du nucléaire les op r et le
démantèlement des réacteurs qu'il
nécessite
or isoler cette filière et notamment des
nerfs et des nez disent qu'ils réalisent
des profits à hauteur de 600 millions
d'euros chaque année
c'est amputer gravement l'entreprise de
sa capacité à investir et à innover de
même le pire c'est que nous connaissons
la suite dans quelques années vous
viendrez nous dire regardez l'entité
publique croule sous les dettes il faut
l'ouvrir au privé pour lui donner de la
capacité à investir bla bla bla bla bla
bla on connaît malheureusement
déjà trop cette symphonie libéral nous
voulons donc savoir s'il est vrai que le
projet recul prévoit la création de ces
trois filières étanche entre elles avec
une holding de tête
le deuxième risque qui nous guette c'est
celui des barrages hydroélectriques
même s'il reste propriété de l'état
parmi les 150 barrages
combien de concessions seront confiés au
privé
car alors que la part du nucléaire
pardonnez-moi avait le masque 30
secondes c'est pas évident car alors que
la part du nucléaire est amené à
décroître dans notre mix énergétique
nous allons remettre au privé une part
considérable de notre énergie pilotable
nécessaires à l'équilibré électrique et
nous courons le risque il se passe la
même chose qu'en californie dans les
années 2000 lorsque le privé avait
organisé le black out pour que les prix
payés par l'état californien soit
suffisamment rémunérateur pour les
actionnaires au mépris total de la
population
vous êtes donc en train de mettre notre
sécurité et notre souveraineté
électrique au même des marchés
financiers en scène vers les problèmes
aujourd'hui en cas de coups durs comme
les grande tempête de 99 le service
public et ses salariés répondent présent
ils compris ceux des départements
voisins
qu'en sera-t-il demain lorsque tout sera
démantelée que direct energie roll
monopole sur une région total sur une
autre et edf
une autre encore nous vous laissons
imaginer les résultats de cette
concurrence pour conclure je voudrais
simplement rappeler qu'en novembre 2016
le candidat emmanuel macron publié un
livre intitulé révolution
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ce qui serait révolutionnaire
aujourd'hui ce serait de cesser de
suivre les vieilles recettes de madame
thatcher et d'arrêter de tout livrer au
marché dans tous les domaines c'est un
désastre
il est temps d'admettre les erreurs qui
ont été commises et d'y remédier plutôt
que de s'obstiner dedans pour les
justifier ce qui serait révolutionnaire
ce serait de renationaliser
edf et gdf d'en faire deux entreprises
publiques disposant d'un monopole public
ce qui serait révolutionnaire
ce serait de constituer un véritable
service public de l'énergie du 20e
siècle
démocratiser cogérer entre les élus les
salariés et les usagers
et si vous le souhaitez nous avons déjà
déposé cette proposition de résolution
au sénat il n'ya plus qu'à la mettre à
l'ordre du jour et à l'adopter
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention et désolé pour ce petit manque
de voix mais je vous remercie de
participer à ce débat
bonne soirée merci chers collègues donc
dans la suite du débat la parole et à
madame denise saint-pé pour l'union
centriste
si le président mes chers collègues
madame la ministre
la réorganisation éventuel du groupe edf
par le projet hercules élaboré par sa
direction à la demande du gouvernement
ne manque pas d'interroger sur le fond
tout d'abord force est de constater que
l'objectif recherché initialement avec
la mise en place de la reine est loin
d'avoir été atteint
imposer à edf de réserver à ses
concurrents français et européens
une partie de sa production nucléaire à
un prix fixe de 42 euros par mégawatt
heure qui n'a maintenant plus bougé
depuis dix ans suscite des
interrogations
le bénéfice annoncé pour le consommateur
sous prétexte de concurrence accrue est
en réalité inexistant avec un prix de
l'électricité sans cesse croissant au
point que la précarité énergétique
auparavant un épiphénomène en france est
aujourd'hui une réalité grandissante de
notre côté de multiples fournisseurs
alternatifs qui ne produisent pas un
kilowattheure d'électricité boursicote
au gré des prix de gros et se
fournissent chez edf
chaque fox et à leur avantage je
comprends donc que l'état négocie
âprement avec bruxelles pour remédier à
cette situation ubuesque qui met à mal
notre champion mondial de l'électricité
pour autant le projet à recul visant à
séparer le groupe edf en trois entités
m'interpelle que l'état souhaite
conserver dans le giron national
un sdf bleus gérant le nucléaire énergie
qui a permis à la france de bénéficier
depuis des décennies de l'électricité la
moins chère d'europe
cela me paraît indispensable je souscris
pleinement à cette approche stratégique
qu'il en est de même pour rené df azur
dédié à la prod2 à la production
hydroélectrique de nos grands bars
j'ai souscrit également sous réserve
néanmoins que les autres exploitants
déjà en place en france comme la chaîne
dans les pyrénées voient également leur
intérêt préserver en revanche
l'ouverture à des capitaux privés d'une
filiale dite verte dédiée aux activités
de fourniture d'électricité aux
particuliers aux entreprises au
développement des nerfs et surtout à la
distribution d'électricité
me paraît plus que hasardeuse sur la
fourniture d'électricité
ce projet acterait la fin des tarifs
réglementés en france ce qui ne me
paraît pas satisfaisant pour les abonnés
concernés
au vu de la situation économique des
prochaines années sur les énergies
renouvelables
je m'inquiète également que l'appât du
gain lié à la promotion du grand t au
lien offshore puissent relayer au second
rang la production d'énergies
renouvelables photovoltaïque ou issus de
la biomasse solution qui valorisent nos
territoires
mais surtout je suis indigné à l'idée
que le réseau de distribution électrique
qui appartient aux collectivités locales
à nos communes et qui a simplement
étaient concédées à aînés 10 puis ce
dépendre des desiderata d'investisseurs
privés cette hypothèse me laisse sans
voix
investir sur le réseau électrique est
une nécessité
ce n'est pas une option les coupures
d'électricité liées aux intempéries
nous le rappellent régulièrement
j'ajoute que la péréquation nationale
issue du turpe est la seule garante d'un
service public de qualité y compris en
zone rurale le principe d'égalité des
usagers du service public en dépend
aussi pourquoi vouloir remettre en
question un système électrique national
qui a fait ses preuves au risque de
transformer avec le projet recul le
groupe et dr
un colosse aux pieds d'argile sur la
forme maintenant
pouvez vous me confirmer madame la
ministre comme projet de loi sera bien
présenté au parlement sur ce sujet comme
vous nous l'aviez annoncé ici au sénat
lors d'une audition au mois de novembre
dernier
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à jean claude
tissot pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la crise sanitaire
économique et sociale que nous
traversons a logiquement relégué au
second plan
de nombreux débats sur l'avenir de notre
pays toutefois les discussions sur notre
politique énergétique
nos impératifs en revenir au premier
plan en ce début d'année je remercie le
groupe crc est d'avoir provoqué ce débat
le secteur énergétique traverse une zone
de turbulences avec des incertitudes et
des changements profonds
la volatilité la baisse des prix
d'énergie des enjeux de la transition
écologique avec la part croissante des
énergies renouvelables ou encore les
difficultés rencontrées pour l'entretien
du parc nucléaire en tant que groupe
intégré à l'ensemble du secteur de
l'énergie edf possède dans un donc un
rôle central en termes d'indépendance
énergétique de notre pays de maîtrise de
notre politique énergétique et de
transition écologique
pourtant les premières annonces du
premier projet recul semble aller
totalement à contre-courant des besoins
que nous impose ses nouveaux défis
en effet le gouvernement propose un
découpage purement capitalistique de cet
opérateur historique formé par le
conseil national de la résistance
ne soyons pas dupes le gouvernement ne
répond pas à une demande de la
commission européenne
il poursuit simplement somme opérations
de démantèlement des entreprises
publiques par des considérations
uniquement financière il est vrai que le
groupe edf a des difficultés mais elles
proviennent de choix politiques
inadaptées et court termiste la
sous-rémunération chronique de l'actif
industriel d'edf par la reine et la
sous-capitalisation par un état
actionnaire irresponsables ont
logiquement conduit à la situation
actuelle d'edf alors que les enjeux de
la transition écologique doit être au
coeur de nos discussions
le démantèlement du groupe edf dans le
projet recul pourrait profondément
remettre en cause nos choix en matière
d'énergie et conduire à une perte de
notre indépendance énergétique
en effet la filiation à l'extrême de
l'ensemble des activités du secteur
énergétique risque de conduire à une
profonde remise en cause de la cohérence
de la filière électrique ainsi la
désintégration de des esprits seraient
totalement le groupe une stratégie
coordonnée à long terme autant dans la
production que dans la distribution
l'exemple des réseaux de distribution
est frappant qu'avec justifie à lui seul
le monopole naturel du secteur
d'électricité par la complexité des
infrastructures et de gestion de ce
réseau dans le prochain dira qu la
société inédit serait intégré un cri
vial dont le capital serait ouvert aux
privés 35% je crois est-ce que les
logiques financières permettront de
gérer un réseau de distribution
performant et également les parties je
crains que non ainsi le contexte
spécifique du marché de l'électricité
implique gouvernement doit disposer
d'une vraie capacité à mettre en oeuvre
une politique énergétique maîtrisé et
souveraine en ce contexte de crise
sociale la maîtrise des prix et la
cohérence de la filière électrique être
notre principale préoccupation maintenir
un tarif identique du kilowattheure pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
quel que soit l'endroit où ils habitent
est une mesure de justice sociale et je
tiens à saluer ici l'engagement des
agents d'edf mobiliser pour défendre une
idée essentielle et ds appartient à tous
l'ensemble des français doivent avoir
leur mot à dire sur ce projet de
démantèlement
d'où notre proposition de référendum
d'initiative partagée concernant une
entité forte
il défend la souveraineté énergétique de
notre pays et plus globalement notre
intérêt général est indispensable pour
répondre à l'urgence écologique et
sociale le groupe socialiste écologique
et républicains s'opposera avec fermeté
au démantèlement du groupe d'edf bien
merci chers collègues la parole à notre
collègue gérard longuet excusez moi
gérard longuet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je suis de
convictions libérales et résolument
européen
et pourtant je les remerciais le groupe
communiste d'avoir inscrit ce débat et
fabien gay m'a réjoui
dans son intervention même si je ne
partage absolument pas ses conclusions
force est de reconnaître force est de
reconnaître que dans ce débat madame la
ministre vous avez une énorme
responsabilité nous une charge belles
charges non pas une culpabilité une
responsabilité
pourquoi parce que vous allez avoir à
combattre la commission européenne et
franchement en cinq minutes je ne
parlerai que d'un seul sujet qui est en
effet l'avenir de l'énergie électrique
nucléaire
il yad'autres énergique l'électricité
l'énergie électrique nucléaire la
commission
l'effet de ces mesures
les quatre paquets en 25 ans les
directives les règlements a
considérablement contribué à affaiblir
le nucléaire dans notre pays parce
qu'elle commet une erreur sur l'analyse
de marché pour qu'il y ait une rencontre
d'une offre et d'une demande il faut
pouvoir équilibrer il faut pouvoir
stocker l'électricité ne se stocke pas
vous l'avez rappelé l'électricité se
transporte mal mais surtout et c'est le
troisième point que méconnaît
complètement la commission c'est que
l'électricité la production électrique
est devenu le résultat de choix
politiques
il se trouve que certains pays européens
récuse le nucléaire c'est leur droit
mais ils doivent en tirer les
conséquences
leur coût de production seront
nécessairement plus élevés surtout sinon
leur impute ce que je souhaite
profondément le coot de la tonne de co2
qu'ils émettent la nature les a dotés
pour nos voisins allemands de charbon de
limites
mais ce n'est pas une
donc pour qu'ils soutiennent la
commission afin d'affaiblir un nucléaire
français qui lui a l'immense mérite de
nous apporter l'indépendance c'est une
nécessité absolue de nous apporter une
réponse écologique pour l'énergie
électrique pas de carbone qui nous
permet d'avoir en situation d'équilibré
de long terme une électricité moins
chère les orateurs l'ontt je suis l'ont
souligné et qui enfin introduit un
soutien l'énergie électrique nucléaire
un secteur de recherche scientifique
technologique industriel plus de deux
cent mille salariés qui nous place en
position de podium médaille d'argent
médaille d'or médaille de bronze au plan
international dans une danse dans une
compétition où nous n'avons pas toujours
de si beaux atouts la reine
on doit le constater après 10 ans
d'expérience est un échec
le taux de centenaires et pas seulement
parce que les 42 euros du mégawatt sont
faibles mais aussi et peut-être surtout
parce que c'est ce qu'on appelle un
piège alors j'allais dire quelque chose
de plus vulgaire mais un piège face edf
perd il ses concurrents ou gagne donc
edf ne peut pas s'en sortir et vous avez
une proposition je ne parle pas de
l'organisation d'edf
je parle de la négociation vous
conduisez avec le
maul c'est laisser la responsabilité du
gouvernement vous avez une porte qui
s'ouvre
vous avez des soutiens le nucléaire
n'appartient pas au passé c'est quand
même extraordinaire de penser que l'une
des plus belles réussites capitaliste
mondiale bill gates investit largement
dans le nucléaire sous des formes
différentes
le smr que la france connaît et que la
france devrait développer plus
rapidement parce qu'il y a une réponse
aux besoins mondiale d'énergie
ekin une réponse décarbonée nous avons
tous les atouts de la réussite et nous
risquons de nous censurer
si ce que vous appelez je crois le
contrat pour défense c'est à dire
cet écart de prix crise récompensés et
qui est au coeur de la négociation avec
bruxelles était adoptée dans mauvaise
condition et quels sont ces mauvaises
conditions
et bien ce serait de retenir ce qui a
été le cas pour la reine un prix de
décroissance un prix de renoncement un
prix de censure en quelque sorte des
capacités industrielles et scientifiques
de notre pays
car si l'on de tarifs le nucléaire au
coût marginal il est évident qu'on ne
peut ni assurer le renouvellement du
patrimoine ni surtout assurer le
développement scientifique industrielle
et technique au moment même on parle de
réacteurs à neutrons rapides de
réacteurs à sodium de fusion nucléaire
on se mutile et bien madame cette
responsabilité
c'est la vôtre c'est celle de votre
gouvernement présidents mc ren est allé
au creusot il a rappelé il a découvert
que le nucléaire n'était pas le
complément du renouvelable
mais la condition du renouvelable il n'y
aura pas de renouvelables il n'y aura
pas d'électricité décarbonée sans
nucléaire
il vous appartient d'avoir le meilleur
accord et que ferez-vous si vous ne le
prenez pas
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole est
désormais à notre collègue franck
menonville pour le groupe les
indépendants monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
depuis quelques semaines l'avenir d'edf
au travers le projet recul est au coeur
de l'actualité
en effet depuis octobre des négociations
entre le gouvernement et la commission
européenne se sont accélérées avec une
certaine opacité
je salue donc la tenue de ce débat
initié par nos collègues du groupe sert
ce au tour de l'avenir d'edf fleuron de
l'état stratège sujet aujourd'hui ô
combien majeur et stratégique comme
chacun le sait les débats liés à la
politique énergétique sont souvent
placées sous le signe du nucléaire la
france a fait le pari de l'atome et ce
pari a été réussi il faut le rappeler
cette formidable aventure industrielle
lancée au milieu du siècle dernier a
donné à notre pays une avance
considérable et des prix compétitifs
grâce à nos ingénieurs grâce à nos
investissements dans ce massif dont nous
tirons aujourd'hui collectivement partie
nous avons eu vrai pour notre
souveraineté énergétique
encore aujourd'hui le nucléaire nous
assure une production d'électricité
décarbonée pilotable est très
compétitive
il est aujourd'hui illusoire d'espérer
atteindre la neutralité carbone dans
notre pays sans le nucléaire cet actif
nationale constitue donc un atout pour
la transition énergétique
ils représentent aussi assurément un
atout concurrentiel pour certains pour
nos concitoyens et nos entreprises
cependant nous devons également faire
preuve de lucidité face à la situation
dans laquelle se trouve notre appareil
de production entièrement détenue par
edf
j'identifie deux principales difficultés
qui sont interdépendantes
la première c'est le vieillissement du
de notre parc nucléaire et la seconde
c'est la tarification applicable à
l'électricité en france
notre parc a été construit en à peine
deux décennies le défi de sa
modernisation nous mais aujourd'hui face
à un mur d'investissements pour
capitaliser sur cet atout mot nationale
il nous faut redonner donc des capacités
d'investissement à edf dans la dèche
chiffre aujourd'hui en dizaines de
milliards d'euros
or cette capacité d'investissement
restent gréve et par l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique
c'est pourquoi il est urgent de
l'adapter avant sa fin programmée en
2026 ce système inadapté même absurde
pénalise l'avenir d'edf et sa capacité
d'investissement
pour conclure je veux livrer une
conviction le nucléaire noah restait un
actif public les enjeux de souveraineté
de sûreté sont trop importants pour nous
que nous soumettions donc nos centrales
nucléaires à des logiques inadaptés de
mise en concurrence et pourquoi là
conclut la constitution d'une entité
100% public dit edf me bleux me paraît
pour le moins indispensable
elle devrait nous permettre d'assurer
collectivement le choix de modernisation
mais il est indispensable dans les mêmes
temps dans les mêmes temps d'assurer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
qui n'ont ni les mêmes contraintes ni
les mêmes avantages
la constitution donc d'une entité
spécifique eu des verts ouverte aux
capitaux privés resterait majoritaire
monde détenu dit on par zf bleus peuvent
certes s'avérer donc pertinente pour
stimuler l'innovation mais de grandes
garanties doit nous être apportée et
nous en manquons je pense notamment au
développement de la filière hydrogène
véritables potentialités d'avenir pour
eux pour edf
mais il me semble nécessaire comme ça à
dieu ça a été dit par des orateurs
précédent d'exclure de ce dispositif
la distribution enfin le 4 particulier
de l'hydraulique
si précieux pour l'économie des
territoires et pour la transition
énergétique doit également rester à
l'abri
l'ouverture de la concurrence et cela
doit nous être garantie dans ces
conditions le projet recul s'il voyait
le jour doit apporter un certain nombre
des 48 doit être porteur aussi d'une
ambition d'avenir pour edf et de
garantir qu'il demeure un nain ensemble
complètement intégrée est contrôlé par
l'état afin d'assurer une stratégie
globale garantissant durablement notre
souveraineté énergétique nous en sommes
loin
par contre un statu quo notamment
concernant la reine serait aujourd'hui
préjudiciable pour l'avenir d'edf
c'est pour cela qu'il faut poursuivre
des échanges déterminée et légitime avec
la commission européenne la france doit
être déterminé lors la défense de ses
intérêts pour garantir l'avenir de notre
géant mondial porteurs de notre
souveraineté énergétique le parlement le
parlement bien évidemment doit être
associé à toutes ces démarches en
transparence avec le moment venu un
véritable projet de loi bien merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
daniel salmon pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
parfait monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
si les écologistes ont rarement été en
accord avec la politique énergétique
mené par edf
une politique jamais débattues
démocratiquement nous reconnaissons le
rôle moteur de cette entreprise stratège
garante d'un service public efficace et
d'une qualité de service reconnu de par
le monde
edf a été fondée sur l'idée que
l'énergie est un bien public
aucun gouvernement n'avait osé imaginer
démanteler edf ce gouvernement prépare
cette dislocation à travers son projet
recul
il porte un coup fatal à ce bien commun
déjà fortement fragilisé ce projet ne
répond ni aux problématiques de
l'entreprise ni aux enjeux énergétiques
du 21e siècle c'est toute la logique
même du service public de l'énergie qui
est mise à mal
cette privatisation d'une partie de
l'activité la partie vendable étant bien
entendu celle constituée des énergies
renouvelables et du réseau se traduira
en termes de perte d'emploi et de baisse
des investissements dans la recherche et
le développement nous posons également
une alerte sur la question des barrages
hydrauliques français première source
d'énergie renouvelable en france
les 150 contrats de concession serait
remis en concurrence comme l'exigent la
commission européenne une mise en
concurrence de ce secteur représenterait
un danger certain pour la sûreté des
usagers et la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
par ailleurs les centrales nucléaires et
les barrages sont indissociables les
barrages du rhône sont fréquemment
utilisées pour le refroidissement des
centrales mais barrage servent également
de stockage remplit lors des périodes de
faible consommation
car il faut le rappeler le nucléaire lui
non plus n'est pas en adéquation avec la
consommation
hercules ne répond pas non plus à la
question des moteurs de l'endettement de
l'entreprise et du portage de la dette
ils n'auront pas à la sous-rémunération
chronique dont souffre l'entreprise
depuis la mise en place de l'accès
régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique
un coup minorée à l'époque pour faire
croire que le nucléaire est peu chère
madame la ministre
la politique énergétique française est
aujourd'hui à un tournant
les décisions prises seront décisives
notamment pour la bonne opérationnalité
la transition énergétique de la france
dans les dix ans à venir la fuite en
avant dans le nucléaire avec la
construction de 6 nouveaux op r comme
l'annoncé de président de la république
tient d'une stratégie énergétique
mortifère pour le pays est intenable
financièrement pour l'entreprise déjà
surendetté à hauteur de 36 milliards
d'euros sans parler des 80 100 milliards
nécessaires au démantèlement et les 25 à
40 milliards pour 6 géo à bure
cette situation est d'autant plus
préoccupante que des f fait face à un
mur d'investissements avec son parc
nucléaire vieillissant et doit bien sûr
investir dans les énergies renouvelables
et le stockage non le modèle de le père
n'est pas l'avenir d'edf flamanville en
est un exemple criant
le coût de ce fiasco et technologiques
et industriels est passé de 3 milliards
à bientôt 10 9 milliards et prévoit un
coût d'électricité de 110 euros du
mégawattheures alors que les récents
appels d'offres pour le photovoltaïque
au sol atteignent 45 euros du
mégawattheure oui garder coûte que coûte
le nucléaire a un prix et le
gouvernement est prêt à cette
désintégration industrielle et la salle
de tout le service public de l'énergie
pour renforcer et maintenir cette
énergie du passé
hercules comme hercule commence avec un
h comme intellipoint la position des
sénateurs et sénatrices écologiste est
assez simple et claire nous demandons
dans un premier temps le retrait
immédiat immédiat de ce projet délétère
nous appelons ensuite à l'ouverture d'un
véritable dialogue avec tous les acteurs
les négociations se poursuivent en ce
moment à bruxelles dans une opacité
totale
il n'est pas acceptable que les
organisations syndicales est la
représentation nationale soit totalement
exclu sur cette question majeure qui
concerne tous les français un véritable
débat national sur l'avenir d'edf pour
répondre à l'urgence climatique et la
viabilité financière et industrielle de
l'entreprise nous paraît indispensable
les crises actuelles nous rappelle
combien un service public fort est
nécessaire pour affronter les défis
sanitaires économiques et climatiques
seul un grand pôle public de l'énergie
peut garantir l'accès de toutes et tous
à ce bien commun face à la précarité
énergétique qui frappe près de 12
millions de foyers en france
il est un droit pour nos concitoyens et
il doit alors être garantie à des tarifs
abordables de madame la ministre la
situation calamiteuse d'edf de place
face à deux choix le vôtre une fuite en
avant pour sauver une énergie obsolètes
qui ne sera jamais rentable et qui
oblige l'état à une renationalisation du
parc nucléaire pour assurer à sa charge
des investissements colossaux
un choix qui mesurent toute rationalité
économique et même de sécurité nationale
les généraux ne distille pas en faisant
allusion à nos centrales la france est
vulnérable en temps de paix indéfendable
en temps de guerre
le deuxième choix qui est le nôtre
arrêter les frais assumer les pertes
d'edf notamment vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires chinois et britanniques et
planifier une sortie progressive du
nucléaire en développant en parallèle
les énergies renouvelables et les
économies d'énergie pour une vraie
indépendance énergétique
cette stratégie qui engage la france sur
deux ou trois décennies mérite un débat
national que vous refusez honteusement
aux françaises et aux français
je vous remercie bien merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
madame marie evrard pour le groupe perd
des pays
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues évoquer l'avenir d'un
grand groupe national et international
comme électricité de france edf suscite
inévitablement des controverses mais le
projet de réorganiser les re
réorganisation hercules mérite mieux que
des caricatures et de surfer sur les
craintes légitimes des salariés de
l'entreprise et des consommateurs au
contraire comme l'a déclaré le président
de la république lors de son discours
relatif à la stratégie et à la méthode
pour la transition écologique de 27
novembre 2018
nous pouvons transformer les colères en
solutions avec edf
notre pays dispose d'un champion
national mais aussi international
ce champion dispose d'un parc de
production d'électricité
parmi les plus décarbonés au monde grâce
au nucléaire et à l'hydroélectricité
c'est une chance et nous pouvons en être
fiers
alors que la transition énergétique et
la décarbonisation de l'économie sont
dans tous les agendas le 8 décembre 2020
le président de la république a rappelé
au cours de sa visite de l'usiné comme
hatton du creusot le choix fait par la
france d'un mix électrique reposant sur
deux sources décarbonés le nucléaire et
les énergies renouvelables
il a affirmé à cette occasion que notre
avenir énergétique et écologique passe
par le nucléaire
le nucléaire cette énergie non seulement
d'écart venez et sur nous assure
également notre statut de grande
puissance
mais le nucléaire n'est pas la solution
unique
c'est pourquoi la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie présenté en
2018 a fixé de nouveaux objectifs
le nucléaire devra représenter 50 % du
mix énergétique de notre pays
en 2035 au lieu de 70 pour cent à
l'heure actuelle électricité d'origine
renouvelable devra passer de 18 % à 40 %
en 2030 les 10 et 11 décembre 2020 le
conseil européen a donné son feu vert à
la composition de la commission
européenne de fixer comme objectif une
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'au moins 55% d'ici 2030 par
rapport à 1990 avec ce choix de mixer
clé électrique national et pour
atteindre cet objectif européen de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre encore
plus ambitieux
il est important pour notre pays que des
f continue à jouer un rôle clé dans la
transition énergétique
pour cela cette réussite française doit
avoir des moyens d'investir à la fois
dans son parc nucléaire existant et de
façon massive dans les revues énergies
renouvelables dans les réseaux et les
autres aspects de la transition
énergétique comme l'hydrogène propres
c'est d'autant plus nécessaire que dans
le même temps les principaux concurrents
européens d'edf investissent massivement
sur tous ces sujets or les mécanismes de
régulation économique de nucléaire et de
l'hydroélectricité instauré il ya
plusieurs années ne sont plus adaptés à
la réalité des marchés de la nécessité
et ne perd plus et ne permettent plus à
edf d'investir dans tous les aspects de
la transition énergétique la régulation
actuelle du parc nucléaire existant ne
permet ainsi plus de garantir la
couverture des coûts et des
investissements nécessaires à son
fonctionnement
depuis la mise en place en 2011 du
dispositif à rennes
edf a en contrepartie de la conservation
de son parc nucléaire
peut vendre jusqu'en 2025 environ 25% de
l'électricité produite par son parc
nucléaire aux autres fournisseurs privés
concurrents l'objectif initial était
d'inciter ces derniers à investir dans
la production d'électricité
mais comme l'avait expliqué le président
directeur général d'edf
lors de son audition le 2 mai 2010 9
devant la commission des affaires
économiques de notre institution
ce dispositif revient à ce que des
investissements publics subventionnent
des acteurs privés dont certains
disposent de moyens considérables tout
en empêchant edf de profiter de du
produit de son travail et sans les
inciter à construire les capacités de
production nouvelles
dans le même temps edf est face à de
nombreux défis avec son parc nucléaire
de 56 réacteurs
initialement estimé à 55 milliards
d'euros le coût des travaux du grand
carénage devrait être beaucoup plus
élevé 100 milliards d'euros selon la
cour des comptes posant la question de
son financement alors que les plus
anciens réacteurs en fonctionnement
dépassent leur quarantième année
d'exploitation
l'allongement de la durée d'exploitation
des réacteurs est un autre enjeu
économique majeur
à cela s'ajoute la revalorisation à la
hausse des coûts globaux des op r inc
les pointes et de flamanville la
construction annoncée de 6 nouveaux
opère en france
en parallèle leydier volet développement
dans l'hydroélectricité deuxième source
de production électrique dans notre pays
sont bloqués dans l'attenté du règlement
des contentieux communautaire parce que
les français ne comprendraient pas que
dsk aurait légué au sol se gonfle un
plan pour relever les défis multiples de
la transition énergétique
le projet
hercules de réorganisation du groupe edf
fruit de négociations européennes parc
particulièrement difficile doit
permettre notre champion national de
tenir son rang
pour autant notre groupe restera
extrêmement vigilants sur la
finalisation de ce projet il n'est pas
question ici de démantèlement d'edf
cette réorganisation du groupe et de ses
activités ne doit en aucun cas cassez le
fleuron de l'énergie français par
ailleurs queen des structures
l'hydroélectrique devenus obsolètes dont
l'ouverture la concurrence a été souvent
repoussées nous attendons enfin que le
projet hercules puisse permettre à edf
de financer tous les aspects de la
transition énergétique et écologique
évoqué en permettant à l'entreprise de
rester aux avant-postes en amateur il
faut conclure donc le la parole est
maintenant à jean claude rich et pour le
groupe rdse
bonjour
jeudi la ministre mes chers collègues
électricité bénéficiant d'un statut
particulier et 15 juillet par le conseil
d'état comment pour lui le prêt à
résister non substituables s'explique
que sa production ne puisse être traité
comme une activité de marché quelconque
depuis l'acte unique européenne dont
vous me direz atur de la concurrence du
marché agité grignote progressivement
notre sol et énergétiques et dans ceux
visant les conséquences le plan de
sabotage
hercules impose une nouvelle séparation
des activités d air en deux ou trois
entités porté par la société holding
et bien c'est bleu portant la production
nucléaire à capitaux 100% publics
éventuellement ces barrages
hydroélectriques qui pourrait toutefois
être cantonné aux scènes de l'entité et
les azur et les verts ouverts aux
capitaux privés incluant les énergies
rural et enée 10 en essence et efficient
le prix de l'arenh pourrait enfin être
heureux à l'horizon pour redonner une
capacité d'investissement qui vivent
certains défauts et lui offrir de la
marge face à son fort endettement
la reine qui contrepartie la situation
politique les ai réussi à 42 euros le
mégawattheure depuis 2012 à raison du
refus par la commission européenne de
toutes les propositions de révision
il pénalise et df et le place dans une
situation inéquitable face à aux
fournisseurs alternatifs qui se tourne
ce soir vers la reine soit vers le
marché de gros soit la justice dès que
cela les arrange
l'ouverture à la concurrence la police
khan ni favoriser l'émergence de
nouvelles capacités de production par
ses fournisseurs alternatifs
ni profiter aux consommateurs la
concurrence artificielle à marche forcée
sur les raisons de ce réseau dans la
nature se pose plus à ce jeu se fait
ainsi au détriment des consommateurs
ce qui n'est pas conforme ni aux
principes généraux du droit à la
concurrence ni aux objectifs de
l'ouverture du marché européen de
l'énergie
la baise et précités n'a pas eu qu'à
lire unique
divoli le groupe rdse ne peut envisager
une maîtrise de la production
énergétique des réseaux s'il ne
demanderait pas dans le giron de l'état
et qu'il garantirait pas la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de la france 2 sur
quoi après tout les subventions
octroyées par les trappes pour le
développement des énergies renouvelables
il serait inacceptable de perdre la main
sur un secteur de rue très rentable le
projet reculade d'ailleurs fait l'objet
de spéculations sur le marché nous
pensons pour notre part que le capital
des pme doivent demeurer lancement
public
la transition énergétique et le respect
de l'accord de paris suppose que l'état
préserve le contentieux nucléaire et
l'ensemble des énergies renouvelables
hydraulique compris avec le risque et
leurs bénéfices nous craignons que la
réorganisation de l'activité des déesses
finissent pas faiblir davantage
nucléaire selon ron dennis ses phrases
elle construit rien c'est par les
contribuables
à contre courant du discours prononcé au
creusot dans lequel le président
république déclaré que l'atome devait
continuer à être un pilier du mix
énergétique pour les décennies à venir
s'il s'agit en revanche d'un vieux
n'émarge étatiques n'ont pas conduit au
marché une partie l'activité
actuellement réalisés par exerce comme
une mise à l'abri des concessions
hydroélectriques face aux exigences de
la commission européenne
quant à laurie la concurrence nous
serions favorables mais nous craignons
que la solution est l'une permettent des
8es est issue la phase de transfert de
20 kg est là si l'abstention des
informations à travers la salle presse
n'est pas acceptable
l'arbre association projet aussi
fondamentale et stratégiques
pourquoi ne pas instaurer une nouvelle
commission champsaur les salariés
citoyens sont totalement exclus de
l'école au cias ion entre la france et
la commission européenne et les
interrogations sont légitimes et c'est
l'étape ultime du processus de
libéralisation engagé
dès les années 90 ou est ce une
tentative de protection des actifs
énergétiques des maternelles ou
préservation du patrimoine nations unies
tic
nous considérons que nous sommes encore
en négociations en cours et rassurer nos
concitoyens
ainsi je laissais l'arrivée quant à
l'avenir souveraineté énergétique la
préservation de l'emploi l'accès de tous
à l'énergie à un prix abordable
la ministre merci d'indiquer dans ce cas
scénario nous sommes afin que nous
puissions nous nous parlons et un autre
tour réalisé noms propres travaux
d'hercule par un positionnement au caire
et argumentée et forestières et la
parabole actuelle l'impression d'être
chez seghers et la société est aussi
puissante et un et lancinante que celle
que produit la dérive des continents
hossein au niveau du détroit de
gibraltar aussi l'écho des reculs qui
pourrait matérialiser le bicamérisme
cher aux croisiens du sénat constitué
deux assemblées seront tes assez fortes
pour résoudre pour résister aux forces
en présence en tout cas il fait le clown
hésitante ne suffira pas merci chers
collègues et la parole est maintenant à
marie-claude varia ce pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
alors que nous sommes au coeur d'une
crise sanitaire économique sans
précédent que chacun s'inquiète des
conséquences il faut bien le dire de la
pandémie sur sa vie quotidienne mais
aussi sur notre futur collectif
le gouvernement se lance en catimini
dans la réorganisation du secteur
électrique français fin 2018 le
président de la république a demandé à
jean bernard lévy président ddf de
réfléchir à la réorganisation des
activités du groupe afin je cite de
renforcer sa contribution la transition
énergétique et de mettre en oeuvre des
orientations définies dans le plan
prévisionnel de l'est
archi or il semble aujourd'hui que loin
des enjeux de transition écologique et
énergétique
c'est bien la poursuite du processus de
libéralisation
initié en quatre ans 1996 qui se profile
avec le projet recul nous l'avons dit et
je pense que nous partageons tous ce
constat le secteur et la filière
électrique dans son ensemble sont des
outils stratégiques essentielles
pourtant comme cela a été souligné lors
du débat d'hier la sécurité
d'approvisionnement restent fragiles
nous sommes par ailleurs dans un
contexte de sous investissement dans la
production électrique
malgré les soutiens financiers colossaux
aux fournisseurs châtelaine alternatif
en effet la part des énergies
renouvelables est encore largement
minoritaire dans la consommation
énergétique des ménages et des
entreprises
loin des objectifs du paquet climat
énergie
celui ci prévoit ainsi à l'horizon 2030
de réduire les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'au moins 40% par rapport à
1990 et de porter la part des énergies
renouvelables à 32%
parallèlement la précarité énergétique
augmente dans notre pays
faut savoir qu'elle touche un ménage sur
cinq pourtant l'électricité est un bien
essentiel et l'accès à l'énergie à un
prix abordable est un droit que l'on
doit garantir à tous les usagers
participant pleinement au droit au
logement décent reconnu à valeur
constitutionnelle
l'état dispose alors d'une
responsabilité première sur
l'organisation de ce secteur
si edf détenu à 83,6 % par l'état reste
un géant au premier rang mondial dont le
chiffre d'affaires atteignait 69
milliards en 2018
il n'en demeure pas moins que le groupe
est endetté à hauteur de 41 milliards
d'euros que le secteur électrique et en
particulier la filière nucléaire est
fragilisé autrefois fierté de la nation
elle est depuis l'accident de fukushima
interrogés et objets de défiance sur la
durée de vie soutenable des centrales
garantissant la sécurité de tous
réduire aider
au nucléaire comme l'a fait le président
macron lors de son discours au creusot
du creusot et mortifère prétendre
résoudre tous ces dysfonctionnements
en généralisant le marché amm et
qu'attend un peu plus cdf en segmentant
les activités et en privatisant les
énergies renouvelables et le réseau de
distribution et tonnes/an sens ce serait
une fuite en avant alors que l'urgence
climatique exige une planification et
des investissements massifs de long
terme incompatible avec le marché
puisqu'il exige une forte maîtrise
publique
nous le répétons encore une fois
l'avenir des ds ne peut se négocier dans
l'opacité et le secret c'est la sphère
de tous
la réponse du premier ministre qui
explique que les négociations avec
bruxelles se poursuivent et qu'aucun
accord n'a été trouvé à ce stade peine à
nous convaincre
il en est de même de la promesse du
maintien d'une entreprise intégrée comme
l'a souligné fabien gay comment des
entités indépendantes
pourront-elles être intégrés d'autant
qu'une note de lagence de participation
de l'état de mes des participations de
l'état de mes 2020 nous rappelle que la
position de la commission européenne est
claire il faut démanteler dfl éclaté en
quatre structure étanche
cette position interdit la mise en place
d'une stratégie de groupe et de toute
politique industrielle cohérente
pire elle permettrait que les filiales
de la holding et df se fassent
concurrence entre elles que dire enfin
de la demande de séparation juridique
des activités nucléaires qui interdirait
que les bénéfices tirés des
investissements déjà amortis ne puisse
être réinvestis dans des activités
nucléaires nouvelle
enfin comme cela a été confirmé par la
réponse du premier ministre aux
organisations syndicales
l'équipement électrique du pays les prix
de l'énergie et l'amélioration du
service public sont les grands absents
de ce projet vous comprendrez mes chers
collègues devant les défis économiques
financiers et techniques que devra
affronter notre système électrique que
ce soit le renouveau de nos réseaux de
distribution
l'augmentation des énergies
renouvelables dans notre mix
énergétique mais aussi les défis du
nouveau nucléaire nous ne pouvons
accepter qu'edf soit nouveau découpé et
le système électrique livrer un peu plus
aux intérêts privés en dehors de tout
contrôle démocratique
c'est le sens de ce débat ce soir et
c'est le sens bien évidemment de notre
opposition projet recul merci chers
collègues
la parole est maintenant à patrick
chauvet pour le groupe union centriste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues le débat proposée
aujourd'hui par nos collègues du groupe
crc eux
concernant l'avenir d'edf le contenu du
projet recul et ses conséquences pour
l'ensemble de l'entreprise est à la fois
aux portes à en termes de calendrier est
légitime dans les interrogations qu'il
suscite
j'aurai donc comme nos autres collègues
de nombreuses questions aux portes à
tout d'abord car des craintes et de
loups et des doutes sont en train de
naître
faute d'informations officielles et de
réponses claires de la part d'edf et du
gouvernement
la presse se fait régulièrement l'écho
du projet recul sans que nous soyons
associés aux réflexions et aux décisions
sans que les salariés ne comprennent
l'avenir qu'on leur trace initié par le
précédent gouvernement qui a demandé au
groupe edf de réfléchir à sa propre
organisation
le projet hercules devra aboutir à une
réorganisation profonde des différentes
composantes du secteur électrique
français que sont les activités de
production de transport de distribution
et de fourniture d'électricité exercée
par le groupe
la présentation officielle de ce projet
devait initialement être effectué en fin
d'année 2010 9 puis repoussé à de
nombreuses reprises en raison de la
prolongation des discussions entre la
france et les institutions européennes
où en est-on madame la ministre
de ce calendrier ce débat est opportun
également car toutes les rumeurs courent
sur le fond du projet recul elles sont
contradictoires et entraîne de
l'inquiétude les nouvelles modalités
d'organisation proposé suggère la
création de plusieurs structures parfois
deux parfois trois on évoque une edf
bleus une déesse verte une des f&a sur
chacune reprend dans une partie des
activités actuelles le nucléaire
l'hydraulique le transport d'électricité
la distribution la fourniture
d'électricité les énergies renouvelables
le périmètre de chaque entité est
également très évolutif l'état détient
quasiment 84 % du groupe edf
c'est donc bien à lui de définir les
objectifs et les ambitions d'un tel
projet de réorganisation
madame la ministre quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement
quels cadres quels objectifs et quelles
ambitions avez vous donné au projet en
recul notre débat est également légitime
sur le fond la réorganisation d'edf
suscite de nombreuses interrogations en
matière juridique d'enjeux sociaux pour
les salariés et d'avenir pour une
entreprise dans un domaine stratégique
j'aimerais en relayer quelques unes
concernant le nucléaire par exemple les
critiques régulières autour du mécanisme
d'accès régulé au nucléaire historique
la reine est une des motivations
principales à la réorganisation du
groupe
celui ci est fortement endetté à hauteur
de 41 milliards d'euros à fin 2010 9 et
fait face à un mur d'investissements
notamment au titre de la rénovation du
parc existant et de la construction de
le p r de flamanville pour contribuer à
ces investissements une réforme de la
reine supposé mieux garantir les revenus
d'edf est sollicité de longue date
edf souhaiterait à la fois
l'augmentation du tarif de la reine et
une refonte du système afin que les
fournisseurs des dommages edf
lorsqu'ils recourent aux marchés de gros
c'est un enjeu essentiel pour le respect
la concurrence sur le marché de
l'énergie mais aussi et surtout pour le
maintien d'un coût abordable pour les
consommateurs
cette réforme doit à notre sens être
concomitante à celle de la
réorganisation du groupe
sans cela le projet recul ne pourra être
acceptée cela implique de présenter
d'importantes sécurité juridique en
matière de respect du droit de la
concurrence et de séparation des
activités dans le projet reculent
néanmoins réformer le marché du
nucléaire ne doit pas conduire à un
démantèlement du groupe historique
français ni à une augmentation des prix
de l'électricité en france
enfin d'un point de vue social la
crainte des salariés s'est manifestée
par deux journées de grève fin 2020 est
il possible de prendre des engagements
sur l'avenir de l'emploi en france pour
le secteur de l'énergie
comment associer vous les salariés dans
cette réorganisation
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est désormais à serge méry
loup pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues démantelé et
privatiser tel semble être les maîtres
mots du gouvernement quand il s'agit du
sort de nos entreprises publiques après
adp l'avenir du groupe et df inquiète le
projet hercules qui va hypothéquer
l'avenir d'un de nos fleurons
industriels et mettre à mal notre
service public de l'énergie et la seule
proposition que le gouvernement a trouvé
pour satisfaire les exigences
européennes salariés collectivités
territoriales élus et consommateurs
montent au créneau pour exprimer leurs
craintes de voir cette entreprise
héritage du conseil national de la
résistance démantelé et l'énergie ce
bien commun soumis aux lois du marché
madame la ministre je souhaite attirer
votre attention sur le devenir des
activités hydroélectriques ce sujet mais
cher commandé par mon département contre
plusieurs barrages et df sur la rivière
dordogne
la commission européenne a mis la france
en demeure pour que ces concessions
soient ouvertes à la concurrence en
respect du droit européen de son propre
cadre législatif
il s'agit de la loi de 2004 relative au
service public de l'électricité et du
gaz et aux entreprises électriques et
gazières et de la loi de 2006 sur l'eau
et les milieux aquatiques
ces textes ont amorcé la dangereuse et
libéralisation des activités droit dect
rick alors que nombre de pays de l'union
européenne ont reçu protéger leur
concession le groupe socialiste s'est
alors fermement opposés à ce processus
en déposant une ppl permettant de
prolonger les concessions
hydroélectriques
aujourd'hui vous affirmé ne pas
souhaiter leur mise en concurrence en
les intégrant des pdf azur
mais quid des concessions n'appartenant
pas et df dans les territoires
l'inquiétude monte
la chaîne filiale d' angie pourrait
faire l'objet d'une mise en concurrence
qui si elles étaient actées menacerait
inexorablement sa survie l'eau n'est pas
un produit quelconque c'est un bien
commun
les barrages sont acteurs de la gestion
de l'eau sur nos territoires
le tourisme la pêche l'irrigation l'eau
potable la régulation des débits donc
des crues dépendent directement de leur
activité la mise en concurrence des
concessions serait un coup dur pour
cette gestion
madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous
assurer que la filialisation de
l'hydroélectricité ne se traduira pas in
fine et par une sortie de l'hydraulique
et des fdf pour faire face aux exigences
de la commission
votre projet de scission ouvre à terme
la brèche vers une désintégration du
groupe dans une logique purement
libérale ce n'est pas acceptable pour
nous socialistes qui tenons au service
public à la préservation de notre
aménagement du territoire
le moment est venu pour que l'état
stratège prennent le pas sur l'état
régulateur où je dirais liquidateur qui
plient devant les diktats de l'union
européenne c'est pourquoi nous avons
décidé de déposer une proposition de
référendum d'initiative partagée
je vous remercie il y un merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
daniel grémillet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il y à 75 ans ici le
général de gaulle affirmé en ces lieux
devant l'assemblée consultative
je cite c'est le rôle de l'état
d'assurer lui-même la mise en valeur des
grandes sources de l'énergie dans
l'immédiat après guerre le retour à la
nation des sources d'énergie adopté par
le conseil national de la résistance
qu'on disait à la création d' edf depuis
lors si l'organisation et les activités
d'edf ont évolué ce groupe continue
d'occuper une place imminente dans notre
politique énergétique et notre activité
économique
c'est un pan incommensurable de notre
héritage collectif auquel les français
sont très attachés
les 165 mille salariés les 49 milliard
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
effectivement comme beaucoup l'ont
évoqué cette entreprise est un fleuron
français et européens que l'on a mis du
temps à construire
face à l'urgence climatique le groupe
est plus que jamais le garant de notre
souveraineté énergétique est le fer de
lance de transition énergétique
dans ce contexte les réformes du marché
de exister engagées par le gouvernement
nous inquiète au plus haut point sur
tous les bancs de l'hémicycle
le gouvernement mène en effet trois
négociations auprès de la commission
européenne sur le dispositif de la reine
le groupe edf est effectivement des
concessions hydrauliques
mon collègue tout à leur valeur a évoqué
le projet des reculs pourrait ainsi
conduire un partage des activités du
groupe les salariés évoquent eux un
démantèlement en plusieurs filiales je
reviens pas sur des bleus des verts des
vases sûrs que tout le monde a déjà
évoqué mais ces réformes mal un ministre
pose de lourdes difficultés tant dans
leurs méthodes que dans leur contenu
s'agissant de la méthode
tout d'abord les négociations sont
conduites dans la plus grande opacité
exclu
tout à la fois parlementaires élus
locaux dès le mois de juin la commission
des affaires économiques du sénat avait
pourtant appelé le gouvernement à
associer le parlement réflexion d'un
exécutif madame la ministre vous avez
indiqué devant cette commission en
novembre
je cite si le projet hercules abouti il
nécessitera une loi et donnera donc lieu
un débat au parlement
alors madame la ministre où en sont les
négociations avec la commission
européenne
quant à ceux ci revo enfin les
parlementaires et des élus locaux à ces
négociations
quels sont le véhicule quel sera le
véhicule juridique et le calendrier
envisagé
pouvez-nous nous confirmer que ces
réformes ne seront pas présentés au
détour d'une lettre rectificative ou
d'un amendement dans les pros des
projets de loi climat ou cadets il faut
respecter madame la ministre le
parlement
c'est un sujet suffisamment important
pour l'avenir de notre économie de notre
pays et notre indépendance énergétique
au service aussi de notre population
pour ce qui concerne leurs contenus ces
réformes que s'élèvent 3,30 légitime
le premier motif de préoccupation tient
au caractère public et intégrée du
nouveau groupe
interrogé par la commission des affaires
économiques
le pdg jean bernard lévy avait indiqué
que la réorganisation devaient être
respectées je cite le caractère intégré
du groupe
nous attendons du gouvernement qu'il
indique comment il entend garantir
l'unicité du groupe
surtout il doit préciser les activités
qu'il entend ouvrir aux capitaux privés
nos élus locaux sont très inquiet par un
éventuel d'ouverture à la concurrence de
notre réseau public de distribution
d'électricité ou de nos concessions
électrique
le deuxième motif de préoccupation a
trait à l'intérêt de ces réformes
sollicité par la même commission jean
bernard lévy avait affirmé que le but de
la réorganisation était de dégager 2
milliard d'euros supplémentaires chaque
année
nous attendons du gouvernement qui
précise l'un
acte financier de ces réformes est ce
seulement la hauteur du mur de
l'investissement auquel edf est
confronté avec une dette de 40 milliards
d'euros le groupe doit avoir doit en
effet parvenir à financer tout à la fois
le grand carénage les chantiers de br ou
encore les énergies renouvelables et
cela sans compter sur la construction
des trois nouvelles pertes de père à
l'étude
le dernier motif de préoccupation
concerne les répercussions de ces
réformes
car elles ont un impact sur les salariés
du groupe c'est un point sur les
concessions des collectivités où le prix
de l'électricité
sur tous ces points le gouvernement doit
apporter des réponses claires à la
représentation nationale
il est dangereux de réformer dans le
brouillard sur un sujet aussi sensible
alors que la crise sanitaire est
toujours devant nous j'aurais aussi
remercié le groupe d'avoir mis ce sujet
effectivement l'ordre du jour c'est un
sujet suffisamment important et on l'a
vu à travers l'intervention de toutes
les sensibilités
le domaine aussi stratégique madame la
ministre qu'il porte pour nos
concitoyens et pour l'avenir de notre
économie
merci merci chers collègues et la parole
aux derniers intervenants michel savin
pour le groupe l'est républicain
je suis président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues depuis 2015 et la loi de
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte
la commission européenne réclame
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
concessions hydroélectriques françaises
aujourd'hui exploités par edf
l'hypothèse de mise en concurrence de
ces concessions soulève de nombreuses
inquiétudes auxquelles ni le
gouvernement ni la commission n'ont
apporté à ce jour de réponse outre leur
fonction de production d'électricité
lebara joue aujourd'hui un rôle
essentiel en termes d'aménagement du
territoire et des questions se posent
alors qu'y at il pas un risque de faire
passer la rentabilité de ces concessions
avant les usages agricoles touristiques
et d'irrigation qui font vivre nos
territoires
le changement climatique un pack
d'ores-et-déjà et va continuer à
impacter nos ressources en eau étant
donné l'intérêt stratégique de cette
ressource vitale
notre pays ne vont ils pas plutôt
affirmer et défendre sa souveraineté
nationale en la matière
l'entretien de ces ouvrages est un
élément essentiel en termes de sécurité
des populations
la multiplication d'opérateurs ne
risque-t-elle pas de compliquer le
travail de réseau de transport
d'électricité ou de son successeur au
risque d'augmenter les risques de black
out quand on sait que ces ouvrages
permettent de gérer les pointes de
consommation mais aussi d'approvisionner
nos centrales nucléaires en eau en cas
de besoin urgent de refroidissement des
réacteurs
enfin cette ouverture à la concurrence
ne risque-t-elle pas de faire gonfler le
prix de l'électricité française des
exploitants privés seront certainement
tenter de maximiser leurs profits au
détriment des consommateurs français
lors d'un précédent débat sur ce juge et
madame elisabeth bornes alors ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
a reconnu devant cette assemblée que la
situation de notre pays est unique en
france
en effet nos voisins ne sont pas soumis
de par leur régime spécifique à la même
obligation de mise en concurrence de
leur exploitation hydroélectrique la
conséquence absurde de cette situation
c'est que la france pourra en faire
figure de bonne élève aux yeux de la com
sion européenne être retrouvée seule en
europe à ouvrir ces concessions et df
notre champion national perdrait ainsi
une part importante de son activité
conscient de cette situation votre
collègue avait mentionné des hypothèses
de travail visant à éviter la mise en
concurrence de nos barrages grâce
notamment à la création de structures
100% public
ces propos font forcément écho
aujourd'hui ou dernier scénario du
projet hercules évoqué dans la presse la
création d'une filiale et df azur dédié
à l'hydroélectricité pourrait selon le
statut qui lui sera donnée jouer ce rôle
de structure 100% public permettant
d'éviter la mise en concurrence
à condition évidemment que ce soit bien
attention au cours de ces derniers mois
madame la ministre vous avez été
régulièrement interrogé par mes
collègues parlementaires sur ce sujet de
la mise en concurrence des concessions
hydroélectriques françaises
à chaque fois vous avez répondu que les
discussions avec la commission
européenne sont en cours et vous vous
êtes réfugiés derrière leur mise en
demeure pour ne pas répondre
cette situation ne peut plus durer nos
concitoyens ont besoin et ont le droit
de savoir quelle politique mène ce
gouvernement
travaillez-vous à l'arrivée de nouveaux
exploitants dans notre pays au nom du
libéralisme ou êtes-vous partisane de la
défense de notre souvenir souveraineté
nationale beaucoup de mes collègues qui
m'ont précédé vous en demandez et vous
en questionner sur ou en sont les
discussions avec la commission
européenne pour moi pour ma part ma
question sera seulement
quelle est votre position sur ce sujet
êtes vous oui ou non favorable à la mise
en concurrence des concessions
hydroélectriques françaises
merci je vous remercie merci chers
collègues et bien madame la ministre
ça fait beaucoup de questions et
d'interrogations convergentes donc vous
avez maintenant la parole
jardin
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
alors ce soir dans l'hémicycle nous
parlant toutes et tous de l'avenir
l'avenir d'un opérateur historique d'un
fleuron national et avec lui une part de
l'avenir de notre pays et je crois que
c'est là un sujet qui dépasse nos
mandats et nos opinions politiques
parce que malgré les clivages nous avons
tous à coeur d'assurer un meilleur
avenir pour notre pays pourtant j'ai
entendu beaucoup beaucoup trop de
contre-vérités et je vais essayer
je vais essayer de rectifier le tir
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
vous le savez le président de la
république l'a redit au creusot le 8
décembre dernier la france a fait le
choix d'un mix électrique décarbonés
avec une part de nucléaire
aujourd'hui nous prenons massivement le
tournant des énergies renouvelables nous
faisons le choix de la résilience de la
transition vers un mix électrique plus
équilibré je m'en réjouis
c'est un choix en responsabilité pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone comme
vous n'avez voter tout en diversifiant
notre approvisionnement et pour faire de
la france une économie écologique
la france est déjà parmi les pays les
plus vertueux de la lutte contre les
changements climatiques en moyenne un
français aimé 20% de moins de gaz à
effet de serre qu'un européen 35% de
moins qu'un allemand oui notre pays
dispose d'une électricité décarbonés et
elle est le socle sur lequel nous
pouvons nous appuyer pour développer la
mobilité électrique comme la production
d'hydrogène non issus des fossiles mais
mesdames et messieurs sénatrice les
sénateurs dire cela ne doit pas nous
empêcher de regarder vers l'avenir
cette performance française elle est le
fruit de l'histoire de choix politiques
qui ont été faits dans un contexte qui
était très différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui
le débat aura lieu en son temps sur
l'évolution du mix de notre production
d'électricité
ce n'est pas le débat de ce soir mais ce
soir j'ai entendu des craintes que vous
avez exprimées
et lorsqu'on parle d'un fleuron français
il est normal qu'il puisse exister des
interrogations des doutes des craintes
même parfois alors je vous dis à ce soir
devant vous en tant que ministre de
l'écologie et de l'énergie peut alors on
nous parlons partout en europe les
concurrents d'edf monte en puissance sur
les énergies renouvelables sur cette
grande révolution telle hydrogène comme
sur l'efficacité énergétique et le
stockage et je le dis tout net ce
gouvernement refuse que la france et edf
soit reléguée au second plan de cette
bataille faute d'avoir su adapter notre
régulation aux évolutions des marchés de
l'énergie
ce serait le prix de l'immobilisme le
prix de l' attentisme et je le refuse
il en vain il en avait parlé de notre
souveraineté de notre rayonnement et il
en va encore une fois tout simplement de
l'avenir de notre pays
alors oui edf doit être un champion
mondial de la transition écologique et
énergétique
c'est l'engagement du gouvernement il
c'est mon engagement et c'est ce que je
suis venu rappeler ce soir atteindre
cette ambition cela demande de regarder
la réalité en face
regardez toute la réalité est qu'elle
est elle aujourd'hui les cadres de
régulation ne sont pas adaptés ils ne
permettent pas à edf de relever cette
ambition il ne lui donne pas les moyens
suffisants pour investir notamment dans
les énergies renouvelables
d'un côté s'agissant du nucléaire le
tarif historique on en a beaucoup parlé
ce soir la reine qui permet à tous les
fournisseurs d'acheter la production
nucléaire à un prix régulé a certes
rempli un rôle en permettant qui émerge
une concurrence dans la fourniture
d'électricité est que les français
puissent choisir librement leur contrat
les fournitures et les fournisseurs
alternatifs assure désormais la
commercialisation de 40% des volumes
d'électricité mais se met pas la
production absolument
mais ce dispositif qui a été créée en
2010 cela a été dit ne permet pas de
garantir correctement la couverture des
coûts et des investissements nécessaires
au fonctionnement du parc nucléaire
existant
son prix n'a plus été révisé et puis des
1012 et vous le savez comme moi le
nucléaire a un coût beaucoup d'entre
vous ont parlé d'un mur
d'investissements la sécurité aussi un
coût la maintenance l'entretien la
modernisation ont un coût de l'autre
côté la régulation de l'hydroélectricité
et je sais que vous y êtes très attaché
vous l'avez rappelé des uns et les
autres mesdames et messieurs et
sénatrices et sénateurs
elle est aussi dépassé notre pays doit
faire face à deux contentieux européen
et disons le clairement ça nous met dans
une situation de blocage aujourd'hui qui
empêche d'engager de nouveaux
développement et la modernisation de nos
installations qui en ont bien besoin
nous deux on a aussi évolué parce qu'il
ne s'agit pas seulement d'électricité
produite par les barrages d'edf
il s'agit aussi et vous l'avez mentionné
de la gestion d'une ressource rare et
précieuse est de plus en plus précieuses
kg alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs oui c'est exact
ce gouvernement a engagé une réflexion
est ouvert une discussion avec bruxelles
en lien étroit avec l'entreprise est
pourquoi pour donner à edf tous les
moyens d'assumer son rôle dans la
transition de notre pays très
concrètement cela veut dire d'abord
garantir le financement du parc
nucléaire existant et donc réformer les
conditions de vente de sa production
oui je crois qu edf doit être rémunéré à
hauteur des coûts qu'elle supporte
d'ailleurs monsieur c'est nature gaie le
monsieur sénateurs gay que j'ai écouté
avec attention et que je n'ai pas
interrompu le projet de régulation du
nucléaire que nous portons vise
précisément à garantir la couverture des
coûts et la rémunération du parc
nucléaire et ce quelles que soient les
évolutions de prix sur les marchés ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
ce serait une garantie très forte
inédite à cette échelle en europe qui
assurerait à edf le fait de disposer des
ressources financières suffisantes pour
faire face aux dépenses liées à
l'exploitation du parc existant y
compris le remboursement de la dette qui
est attaché les consommateurs français
doivent être protégés contre les
variations imprévues
des prix de gros avec un prix de
l'énergie nucléaire existante stable et
prévisible ne fluctuent en pas au gré
des variations de marché
à ce titre je veux rassurer madame la
sénatrice saint pée l'évolution de
l'organisation du groupe n'aura aucun
impact sur l'existence des tarifs
réglementés et la péréquation ne sera
pas remise en cause c'est avec ces deux
principes au coeur qui nous poursuivons
la discussion
de même nous entendons mettre un terme
au contentieux sur les concessions
hydrauliques d'edf car notre objectif
est simple conforter le parc hydraulique
en permettant à edf de conserver la
gestion de ces concessions sans mise en
concurrence
alors vous voyez nous ne cachons rien
rien aux ambitions et rien de notre
exigence
bien sûr certains voudraient faire
croire que la discrétion qui préside à
ce type de négociations et qui préside à
tout type de négociations avec bruxelles
et 2,6 et le signe d'un complot pour je
ne sais quel résultat
mais je le redis j'ai le dis et je le
redis ici devant vous notre seul mandat
notre unique exigence est d'aboutir à
cette évolution majeure de la régulation
parce qu'elle est en faveur d'edf de la
protection du consommateur et de notre
politique énergétique
parce que notre pays a tout à y gagner
et comme nous n'avons rien à cacher je
le dis avec la plus grande clarté
oui ces évolutions si nous arrivons à un
accord nécessiteront une modification de
certaines des structures internes du
groupe
la commission sera attentive à la
manière dont les activités de production
réguler seront organisées par rapport
aux autres activités du groupe
mais les aimants être clair jusqu'au
bout car ce soir
comme depuis le début de ce projet trois
contrevérités continue à être professé
non nous n'allons pas dépenser edf comme
vous le présente comme vous le prétendez
non nous n'allons pas non plus
démanteler le groupe et non
et oui évidemment nous préserverons le
statut des salariés auxquels je veux ce
soir rendre hommage et que je veux
rassurer
sedan ce dont nous parlons ce soir c'est
bien de doter edf d'une structure à même
de pérenniser ses activités d'accroître
ses perspectives de développement et de
financer sa croissance et pour assurer
le financement des parc nucléaire et
hydroélectrique tout en constituant un
grand champion des nouveaux métiers de
la transition alors avec ce projet les
parcours professionnels des personnels
d'edf seront préservés le statut des
industries électrique et gazière sera
préservée et l'ensemble des activités
restera détenu très majoritairement par
edf dans le cadre d'un groupe public est
intègre et je rappelle que
l'actionnariat privé existe déjà dans
l'edf
la question est et on pourra l'envisager
c'est par exemple de mettre des plafonds
et ça ça fera partie du débat parce que
oui mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs
les sénateurs
edf est une entreprise publique et le
restera cela fait partie de l'adn du
groupe et même je crois d'une phare de
l'adn français mais nous ne sommes qu'au
début de ce chantier
à ce stade nous ne sommes pas encore
parvenus à un accord global avec la
commission européenne et les échanges se
poursuivent cela prend du temps mais
c'est aussi parce que le gouvernement
tient bon sur les points essentiels du
projet et parce qu'on veut qu'il soit
solide et si cette négociation ouvre le
champ des possibles je le dis devant
vous jamais elle ne préemptera la voix
des élus de la nation et l'indispensable
discussion parlementaire sur l'avenir
d'edf avant toute réforme et je vous
confirme que cette discussion ne se fera
pas dans le cadre d'un projet de loi
climat et résilience ou dans le cadre
d'un projet de loi 4d ce sera une
discussion spécifique sur ce sujet de
même une réorganisation ne peut se faire
qu'en des battants et en décidant dans
le cadre des instances de gouvernance du
groupe avec les partenaires sociaux
je m'y engage car je crois que ce
dialogue se débat à venir c'est beaucoup
plus qu'une obligation légale ou
politique
c'est le gage de la meilleure décision
pour le pays voilà mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs ce
que je voulais vous dire ce soir loi des
rumeurs loin des contre vérités loin des
peurs avec ce projet nous entendons
donner à edf les moyens de rester le
premier électricien bas carbone d'europe
en sécurisant le financement de son
parti story et en dégageant les moyens
nécessaires pour devenir un champion de
la transition énergétique nul
démantèlement nul dépeçage nul remise en
cause du statut des salariés n'était au
programme
c'est bien à assurer l'avenir de la
transition énergétique de la france que
le gouvernement travaille et vous pouvez
compter sur ma totale détermination
je vous remercie
[Musique]